the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so before we begin today is bit on dose
dosimetry and background radiation I
promised you guys a story about how to
use 2201 to get out of apartheid South
Africa
so I got told this story when my cousin
was about to get married because he
needed a diamond and he was gonna go buy
one and his dad said don't so back in
the 70s when my uncle and his family
were living in South Africa anyone who
wasn't Dutch white so that would be
blacks Jews including us anyone else was
considered second-class citizens by the
apartheid government and you were
allowed to leave because they didn't
want you there but you had to surrender
all of your funds to the government in
order to leave which is you know give me
everything you have and then you can
leave the country penniless it's not a
winning proposition so my uncle and his
brother devised a pretty brilliant idea
to get their funds out of South Africa
unnoticed
they were both dentists or radiologists
or some sort of medical doctor that
requires x-ray reading so one of them
gave the other one all of his money then
reported bank statements to the
apartheid government and said I'm pretty
much piling up penniless my practice
went broke I want to leave the country
and they said okay get out of here so he
went to the u.s. established a dental or
radiological or some other sort of
practice I forget which one and started
requesting his brother back in South
Africa to send him x-rays to read to
help boost his business because that was
their actual business it was pretty
legit so then my uncle would send him
packets of x-rays to interpret and send
back except that every you know there
would be ten x-rays on the front and ten
on the bottom and the middle eighty
whidbey hollowed out now that would that
would have ordinarily have tripped off
alarms because any change in density
would trigger a change in x-ray contrast
because these packages were being
inspected by x-ray and if it looked like
these x-rays were Hollow and you're
smuggling something out they'd be caught
and confiscated so what sort of
materials are valuable that you find in
South Africa that are pretty similar in
x-ray contrast to other light media like
film diamonds
so the remaining brother went and
converted all of his life savings into
diamonds which is something that you can
do in South Africa because this is where
diamonds come from he then slowly over a
period of months or years sent packets
of hollow x-rays full of diamonds to his
brother in the States knowing full well
that the mass attenuation coefficients
of soft tissue and carbon are pretty
similar and so are their densities so
their total attenuation coefficients are
pretty similar to let's pull those up so
we can check it carbon graphite
I'm gonna have a new tab and bring up
soft tissue and we can compare them
let's say what's the what's the most
similar as long as you can see it thing
to film what should we call film here
x-ray film
photographic emulsion how about that is
there something Kodak okay where's the
Kodak standard nuclear I don't think
that sounds right let's go with
polyethylene and plastic carbon plastic
carbon plastic carbon plastic basically
identical so this is a way they were
able to smuggle wealth out of the
country without x-ray contrast tripping
off the guards and once all the slave
savings had been converted into diamonds
he then went to the government and said
I'm penniless my practice won't grow it
broke I want to get out of here and they
said good riddance yeah so they were
able to restart their life in the States
with all of the money that they had had
in South Africa and when my cousin
wanted to get married and said I'm
thinking of buying a diamond my uncle
just said oh don't he's like what don't
get married no don't buy a diamond here
let me take you to the diamond drawer
yeah because there was something left
over so he said pick out an extra
diamond and that's the story of my
cousin's engagement ring as well as why
part of my family's here in the states
yeah very very nuclear diamond story you
know diamonds aren't forever as the
finish have shown us but they can get
you out of repressive regimes okay back
to the DOS stuff so today and for the
rest of the course we get into
biological and chemical effects of
radiation as soon as this pops up and so
in the first slide is everything you
need to know about dose and units don't
worry it's not up there yet I know that
different units of dose are a common
point of confusion so I wanted to put
everything on one slide so you can refer
back to it like a cheat sheet so you've
probably heard of the roentgen before
you've definitely seen the roentgen as a
unit because you've all looked in those
pen or pocket dosimeter z-- that you
actually had at the nuclear reactor when
you guys took a tour of it and control
the control rods the Renkin is not
really a unit that we use much anymore
for for very careful calculations
because you have to do some tissue
equivalency stuff in order to go from
Ayana
stations in air which is what it
actually measures it's a mount of charge
dissipated or built up in air to some
damage to soft tissue and the way you
actually calculate renkins from first
principles linking the physics and the
biology part is remember this equation
here stopping power which is some energy
transfer divided by the energy required
to make an ion each one of those will
give one electron unit of charge towards
those coulombs and so this is the direct
link between the physics and the
chemistry biology in this course it's
not something that's done that carefully
in any of the readings which is why I'm
gonna harp on it here in lecture is
these two parts of the course are often
taught differently and they're actually
totally related and everything's all the
same which is kind of nice you don't
have to just relearn a whole new lingo
in field then there's the SI units of
dose the ones that when you do
calculations in the homework and the
rest of your life I recommend that you
use whenever possible because they're in
units that we're familiar with in
standard units the one where you start
with all along is the gray a gray is the
simple measure of absorbed energy in
joules per kilogram of whatever and so
calculating it is fairly straightforward
- for example if you want to know what
sort of dose you would get in gray from
absorbing gamma rays you can use this
old equation from the first third of the
course and if you integrate this from
the let's say over the range of whatever
object or person you happen to be a
radiating you'll get some fractional
difference in intensity that multiplied
by the original intensity of gammas
which could be given and maybe gamma
rays per centimeter squared per second
maybe times time to get total number of
gammas per centimeter squared multiplied
all that multiplied by the energy of
each gamma divided by the mass of
whatever is doing the absorbing equals
your dose and great so you can use all
the old stuff
from previous parts of the course
directly to calculate dose and grain and
this is the starting point for any
calculation if you don't know what
tissue is exposed what type of radiation
provides what biological effectiveness
it doesn't matter you just start here
then the other unit you may have seen is
a unit not of energy absorption but of
increased risk for something going wrong
in the biological sense it's called the
sievert for simple things like whole
body dose from gamma rays sieverts
equals gray because sievert is
multiplied by this quality factor or
this effectiveness factor that q factor
is actually a couple of factors there's
a queue for the type of tissue and
there's a queue for the type of
radiation and the total quality factor
for whatever you're trying to calculate
is just the multiplication of these two
and so it's fairly easy if you're ever
dealing with whole body gamma dose GRA
equals sieverts if you're dealing with
pretty much anything different gray does
not equal sieverts there'll be just some
factor to add in which can be looked up
from a lookup table but as you've told
you before I don't like that explanation
look it up in a table we're going to
explore why the look-up tables are
constructed the way they are and then
there's the CGS units the ones that are
based in centimeter grams second instead
of kilogram meter second the rad is a
simple measure it's let's say a hundred
rad is just one gray where the rat
actually comes from as its defined as a
hundred eggs absorbed energy per gram
where an ERG is ten to the minus seven
joules and a gram is ten to the minus
three kilograms and so you can do the
mental math there to make sure these all
work out and then a REM a roentgen
equivalent man is just a hundredth of a
sievert so there's historical basis for
this back in the day more folks to use
CGS units there's been a push to SI
units which I happen to like because
everything works out
and you don't have to remember things
like ten to the minus seven joules or
whatever like that
so I'd say when in doubt for equal
comparisons always use the SI units and
always start with the gray because
that's something where you can take a
physical calculation of energy per
kilogram and go into some increased
cancer risk by using the dose quality
factors so let's take a look at how
these appear first of all gammas x-rays
electrons positrons of any le t le t as
i mentioned before is linear energy
transfer and to put this mathematically
you've actually seen this before which
would be some change in energy over some
change in distance it's the stopping
power it's not like the stopping power
it's the stopping power so with the
formulas you got in the second half of
this class you can calculate linear
energy transfer now why are these things
given in let's say discrete tables or
now what's currently recommended is
these functions does anyone have any
idea
how many of your course seven friends
know the formula for stopping power or
could parse it even her understand it
you don't have to not everybody has to
so for the rest of us there are simpler
empirical relations or relations that
get the numbers right that aren't
necessarily based on physics so a simple
lookup table for those who don't have
time to take 20 201 or something beyond
is the easiest thing to do and in most
cases it works it's not exact but it's
probably close enough given
uncertainties in the amount of radiation
that one could absorb or the weight of a
certain organ or the energy of some
x-ray tube
I think these these empirical things are
pretty much good enough and what this
tells you is that there's some
effectiveness of different types of
radiation and different energies of
radiation at imparting energy to the
parts of cells and organs that cause
damage to say that in a little smaller
sentence different energies of radiation
can have different effects biologically
and these tissue factors account for
that it's also a table I want you to
keep in mind because you're going to
have to do a calculation about it
the principal elements in soft tissue in
unit density otherwise known as number
density what you've seen before if you
want to calculate the dose using a
stopping power formula to a human you
have to know what this human is made of
and this is a pretty good assumption and
this is something you'll be doing on
homework number eight is finding the
dose that you're giving to each other in
a particular situation if anyone's seen
the particular situation check OCW for
last year's course and you'll see what
that situation will be
has everyone gotten your whole body
counts at the EHS office if anyone
hasn't do them in the next week because
you'll need that data for the homework
you'll also need this table because if
you think about it if you want to say
well what's the damage by electrons to
soft tissue and you want to calculate
this from scratch you have these four
number densities so we'll keep those in
account and let's put up the formula for
stopping power for ionization stopping
power again
comes out with four PI K naught squared
little Z squared big Z number density e
to the fourth over MeV squared log let's
see what goes on top again oh yeah
two MeV squared over the mean ionization
energy the nonrelativistic form which of
these terms vary depending on the atom
that an electron or whatever would
strike a circle of this there's a couple
big Z what the electrons hitting and the
number density yes the iron is mean
ionization potential so these three
terms are the only things that changed
when you're doing a stopping power to
dose calculation so if you want to get
the total dose in gray to a human you
have to sum over these four different
isotopes actually wait let me put all
the other junk in front to make it
quicker so the four PI K naught squared
little Z squared e to the fourth over
MeV squared is just a constant times the
sum over all your isotopes of zi the
number density of isotope I which inside
there has the element fraction of that
times the log of 2 MeV squared over the
mean ionization potential of isotope I
and in this case notice there's no
isotopes given they're just given as
elements why do we do that why don't we
care for humans
how many isotopes of hydrogen tend to
exist in you
one pretty much one two about five
significant digits you'll all have a
little deuterium something like one in
every twenty thousand atoms of hydrogen
is deuterium but it's it's not a lot I
think it's even less than that
carbons just carbon-12 except for the
tiny amount of carbon-14 you're used for
radiocarbon dating oxygen oxygen think
what sixteen nitrogen's nitrogen 14 so
as long as you know what isotopes to use
you'll know what Z's what I bars and the
number densities given here so this
right here is how you calculate dose and
gray to a human over some distance then
all you'd have to do is integrate that
over your let's say thickness of the
human whatever that happens to be and
you get the total amount of dose
imparted to them so a lot of questions
came up in last year's class how do we
actually do these calculations well this
is how right here first separate out
everything that's a constant because you
only have to calculate it once as I hope
problem set seven and six taught you
guys is separate out whatever you can
first and don't repeat yourself then sum
over all the things that are unique to
each isotope and inside this number
density is the fraction of that isotope
at every human so it's all built in so
these calculations aren't that bad since
you know how to do stopping power you
can take out two-thirds of the terms I
don't know I still have this it's not
terrible so can anyone not see through
how to do this alright yeah question
the mean ionization potential can be
usually approximated as about 10
electron volts times Z except for the
very light isotopes like hydrogen it's
somewhere between 10 and 19 Evy I would
say one you can just look them up or two
you can use this empirical relation to
get a good approximation and empiricism
definitely enters into the biological
world because uncertainty is abound and
it's not always worth being ultra crazy
exact although you can't hurt any other
questions on how to actually carry out a
dose calculation using stopping power
hopefully it's pretty straightforward
guess we'll find out on the homework the
other quality factors to mention there's
been some different there are some
different ideas about these quality
factors notice the scales are fairly
coarse so again there's a lot of
uncertainty or slop in these values but
notice that for let's say x-rays gammas
betas of all energies and charges the
quality factors one why do you think
that is let's go for the case of x-rays
or gamma x' what tends to be the
attenuation coefficient of any photon in
soft-tissue of considerable energy
pretty low and the amount of energy that
can be transferred by those photons is
variable anywhere from pretty low to
pretty high and so the resulting
electron cascade isn't going to be that
damaging and it might not even be that
localized so let's say if you really
want to know how much damages are going
to go due to the DNA of a cell where it
could mutate and cause cancer
not that much most of the gammas passed
through you and the ones that do get
absorbed can have rather long energy
deposition tracks neutrons however
interact nuclear stopping power well so
they just interact with the nuclei of
you or whatever they are radiating and
so when you knock out a nucleus it can
then slam in
two other atoms causing a huge and dense
cascade of ionization if that cascade
happens to be near the nucleus of a cell
you better believe it's going to cause a
lot of damage and that's why these more
energetic neutrons have a much higher
quality factor because they're much
better at causing damage until you reach
some sort of threshold why do you think
it goes down at higher energies yep
absolutely right around 2 MeV or 1 MeV
these cross-sections tend to go down if
we look at the cross section for
neutrons and anything
let's look at hydrogen you guys still
that I do the screen Cloney thing again
just bear with me let's look at any old
cross-section for let's say neutron
scattering and I don't know oxygen we've
looked at hydrogen enough already
cool see that
oxygen-16 we have
incident neutrons elastic scattering the
bouncing off let's look at the form of
this cross-section right around one MeV
things start to dip and so yeah the
probability of any sort of interaction
is going to go down in addition the atom
that's struck has a much higher energy
and therefore a higher range so so
chances are even if the neutron strikes
an atom near the nucleus it will have a
higher range and can travel farther
before that secondary cascade ends up
depositing most of its damage at a lower
energy so if you remember for the
stopping power for ionization or nuclear
stopping power they both look the same
so I'm not gonna label which one it's
fairly low at high energies peaks at a
rather low energy and then comes down so
it's at the end of the range of whatever
particle whether it be the neutron or
the atoms that it's struck that it does
the most damage so you can kind of think
like all forms of radiation except for
photons as armor-piercing bullets they
don't do damage right where they enter
they do damage right where they stop and
explode in the case of armor-piercing
bullets it's a literal explosion in the
case of neutrons electrons protons heavy
ions it's at the end of their range they
have the most stopping power and that's
where the dense Cascades gonna be so
chances are again if the neutron happens
to interact with the nucleus of a cell
say that's the simplest cell I can draw
if a neutron comes in and strikes
another atom it may move far away before
it's armor-piercing explosion let's see
the other ones for protons depending on
which book you go to you get a different
effectiveness it's higher than that of
gammas and x-rays and electrons because
you get a big cascade at the end and
alpha particles really really damaging
and energy is like even a few MeV they
have a very short range they tend to
deposit a ton of energy and that's why
they have a huge effectiveness
is also why alphas are the that's the
one cook you don't want to eat if you
guys remember this before cookies
problem never eat the Alpha it's not
gonna get in through your skin but if it
gets into your body and incorporated
into the material directly surrounding
your nucleus that's how things go really
bad
that's why smokings so bad did anyone
end up getting into a smoke shop to do
that measurement I did check the one by
my house and they just put up a sign
that said no one under 21 so you guys
are right about that
that weird law whatever now let's look
at the tissue weighting factors we've
talked about the issue they've talked
about the factors for different types of
radiation it also matters what tissue it
enters so for things like skin or bone
surface you think of these tissues as
not that critical if you get a scratch
and you lose some skin it's not that bad
for the body same thing if a little bone
chip flakes off you might get shin
splints but it's not so bad not for the
same reason these tissues aren't
dividing very fast the surface of your
bone the hard part
it's basically standing still it's just
calcified minerals with some osteocytes
trapped in there not much happens what's
happening in these tissues constantly
gonads bone marrow colon lung stomach
yep this is where stem cells and fat
rapidly dividing cells tend to be found
so there's been some theories in some
papers saying whatever cancer you're
going to get you probably already got it
in the first few years of life when
you're just a big rolling sack of stem
cells this is part of why occupational
hazards for infants and pregnant women
are much much lower because they are
giant sacks of stationary stem cells and
you don't want to irradiated Steve IDing
really really fast and so the older you
are that's more okay it is to get more
and more radiation dose because a lot of
these effects take a long time to
manifest because they all start with a
single cell and it takes a long time for
that single cell to exponentially grow
and divide over a long time scale into a
mass that'd be considered a tumor so
it's you know a little worrying to think
okay probably most of the cancer I'll
get I got when I was five but then again
it means don't worry about it what can
you do you can there's what it's for
yeah it's free it's done not all of it
you can still limit your dose because
will one any acute radiation exposure
will have short term health effects and
to your cells are still dividing a you
know as what am i as we had a seminar
speaker say a biological organism at
static equilibrium is not very
interesting it's dead it's not dividing
anymore so your cells are still dividing
it still means you should minimize
radiation exposure but a lot of what
happened already happened and if you can
see here the pattern is well the more
rapidly the cells are dividing the more
it has this tissue equivalent issue
quality factor because the more the more
quickly these effects would manifest
themselves and the more quickly the
cells may divide with that mutation
before the cellular repair mechanisms
fix that mutation before a division
we'll get into a lot of that when we
talk about biological effects probably
next week so now how do you do a
calculation of dose in sieverts first
you can take the dose in gray like we
have over here multiplied by these
radiation weighting factors and you get
a
total amount of dose to that tissue
where that tissue may be a certain organ
a part of your muscle whole body if it
was a broad you know blast of radiation
from a bomb far away or something like
that
and you get these single doses to tissue
where each of these radiation equivalent
factors can be equated to this average
quality factor where you integrate the
quality factor as a function of length
times the dose at that length this is
where the stopping power formula comes
in is you'll have a stopping power as
the energy decreases as the particle
moves through the material and it's
stopping power will change so then you
have to integrate that stopping power
times some constants and stuff over that
distance times the quality at that
distance to get the simple weighting
factor you then take these weighting
factors plug them into your dose to
tissue and sum up all the exposures to
different tissues so each tissue will
have its own dose and sieverts it'll
have its own tissue weighting factor you
sum up all the tissues exposed and you
get the total effective dose to the
whole body this means that some organs
incurred dose faster than others for the
same radiation exposure so the whole
body dose should sum up to one and I
believe I remember doing this
calculation but it may be worth your
while to just try it
these numbers should sum up to one
because all of these individual organs
plus the remainder of your body should
constitute the whole body and so this is
in a nutshell how you do these dose
calculations so let's take an example
from the actual reading let's say a
worker gets 14 milligram whole body dose
this would just be from background
radiation cosmic rays food whatever plus
a targeted dose of 8 milligram from
alphas plus a hundred eighty milligram
betas in the thyroid anyone know why
they chose alphas in the lung and betas
in the thyroid what's the most likely
sore
of those iodine and let's say smoking
yeah yep exactly is as we saw a lot of
the radon daughter products tend to be
alpha emitters and you tend to inhale
those through the lungs and iodine is a
beta decay with about a half with about
an eight-day half-life and that gets
preferentially absorbed in the thyroid
so this is a pretty realistic scenario
and we'd say how much effective dose did
this person get to do this calculation
you first the list goes through those
steps you look at the dose to each
tissue times the effectiveness for that
type of radiation so the dose got eight
mil agree Alfa's so you multiply by 24
that quality factor and the lung gets
160 millisieverts you do the
multiplication for the thyroid the
multiplication for the whole body and
then you do a summation of these single
tissue doses here here and here times
the tissue weighting factors which you
then look up from that table or
calculate from the cell division rate
here here and here and you get a total
dose of 42 millisieverts so I want to
point something out to you guys
his thyroid got a hundred eighty
millisieverts he got 42 millisieverts
interesting sounds a little
counterintuitive but in this case these
doses for each tissue are calculated for
that tissue so if you have a probability
of organ failure or mutation you can now
then know how much increased risk he may
have of thyroid cancer specifically or
sum it up to an equivalent whole body
risk and it just so happens you're only
allowed about 50 millisieverts of
exposure so he'd only be allowed another
eight but we'll get into limits and what
this I see are you whatever whatever
means actually show you the document
it's also posted online this in term at
International Committee on radiation you
I forget what the U is but this is the
whole document that for that has the
basis for these recommendations the
numbers and the reasons and that's all
online for you guys to check through so
anyone have any questions on a example
dose calculation
cool let's look at some of the ways that
you'd actually measure dose one of them
we looked at the first day of class the
old Chadwick experiment send radiation
through a fixed amount of area so you
know the flux if you know the total
amount of gammas being produced by this
x-ray tube you know the area then you
know the solid angle you know the flux
then you have just a free air chamber
with a high voltage to suck up those
ions before they recombine and that's
how you can calculate things like dose
and roentgens you also have pocket
versions of these things sealed tubes
with two electrically insulated
electrodes and that cannot discharge
unless ions in the gas allow them to and
this is the basis behind these civil
defense air wall chambers one of which I
happen to have right here so I want to
pass this around and let you guys take a
look at it like the ones you saw in the
reactor you can look through and see a
little needle that will tell you the not
dose but the amount of ionization this
thing has received in roentgens which
can then be equated with some
calculations to dose and soft-tissue and
also there's the base for the
civil-defense dosimeter I want to tell
you guys how it works it's a battery
that's it you open that thing up there's
a couple of big D cells in there and I
ran a voltage divider and you just turn
the knob which sounds complicated all
you're doing is turning a potentiometer
to decide at what voltage this wire end
inside of the tube will be and that
voltage deflects the wire a little bit
by just cool ah back attraction or
repulsion bends it and gives you the
dose and it stays there nothing can get
in or out of that sealed chamber except
penetrating radiation when gammas or
some are neutrons get through they can
cause ionizations in the gas those gas
ions can move to these electrodes
partially neutralizing them making the
needle tilt a little farther and a
little farther so the interesting thing
is when that needle reads zero roentgens
it's fully charged and as the detector
discharges from radiation interactions
the needle moves higher on the roentgens
scale because you can paint whatever
scale you want on it as long as the
physics works out so it's kind of neat
to think that the charge is highest when
the dose is lowest because all the
charges doing is deflecting that little
needle quite simple design and quite
robust these things were designed by
civil defense in case of a the case the
Cold War became a hot war and they'd
have to last for a very long time so
having had this one for about ten years
I can tell you I've not yet filled the
meter which is probably a good thing and
I took that on flights across the world
and hiking in Nepal where the background
dose was considerably higher and the
needle moved like half a roentgen for
the entire three weeks up at elevation
and plane rides and I got more dose on
the plane ride than I did on the hike
interesting fun fact like the ones use
that's pretty much exactly what you
should see and so Alex tells me these
things are starting to get kind of rare
on eBay and that's a shame because this
is the best possible teaching dosimeter
there is if you understand 802 and a
little bit of radiation you know how
these work and can predict what the dose
is actually going to be now how do you
do things like detect neutrons if you
want to detect neutrons you want a good
moderator because well moderated Neutron
deposit all their energy in the detector
instead of bouncing off transferring a
little energy and leaving if you want to
know how many and what energy neutrons
you have you can fill a similar chamber
that's got a high voltage it's got wire
on the inside but instead of air or you
know some other gas in there you can
fill it with things like ethylene or
propylene or some sort of very
hydrogenous hydrocarbon gas something
full of hydrogen to act as a good
moderator that hydrogen ion then becomes
a proton which then damages a lot of
other ions causing an ionization cascade
and leading to some current pulse just
like any other detector there's going to
be some movement of current which is
picked up as damage
you might then ask also why is that
alpha source there anyone have any idea
that's your calibration source so as
that gas in this chamber is attacked by
neutrons you will be blasting some of
the hydrogen ions there hydrogen atoms
out of the ethylene or propylene or
whatever gas you have the gas will
change in effectiveness over time the
energy of the alpha particles will not
so that is your absolutely fixed energy
calibration source so you know exactly
if let's say three point seven two MeV
alphas make a current pulse of a certain
height then you can equate that to a
three point seven two MeV Neutron that
would strike a hydrogen atom and because
the gas degrades over time you have to
recalibrate with that built-in alpha and
any sort of shutter like a you know a
little piece of foil will block the
alpha so that you can use it as a
neutron detector quite clever design in
my opinion it accounts for the
degradation of the gas in the detector
anyone seen one of these things before
okay then there's the Geiger counter
which is an ionization counter run in
avalanche mode you can use these free
air ionization chambers or other
counters as a an energy proportional
counter where a higher energy particle
will impart a bigger ionization cascade
and you can use that to get energy
resolution or you crank up the voltage
like crazy so that any count of any
energy causes an intense ionization
cascade and a huge current pulse and
this is the basis behind chief geiger
counters like the ones we build in our
department those old Soviet SPM 20 tubes
that we've actually bits actually been
survived being stepped on and crushed as
long as the electrodes don't short out
they still work so there's a few folks
in the department that have clearly bent
geiger tubes that one of them looks like
they've been chewed but they still work
because any sort of anything interacting
with the gas will cause an ionization
cascade which is immediately sucked into
the electrodes
by a high voltage and collected as a
current pulse and that's just a cutaway
of what it looks like on the inside and
this is the circuit for a Geiger counter
there is a voltage a resistor a
capacitor and a tube that's all you need
everything else in the MIT Geiger
counter is there to make lights and
sound it's just for fun but the actual
Geiger counter itself can be made
incredibly compact the bigger the tube
the more radiation it will catch just
cuz of its size but otherwise as long as
you get the voltage high enough to cause
this ionization cascade it works it's
really really robust so I want to skip
ahead for some of that stuff and then
talk about how do you measure dose in
humans who here has seen one of these TL
DS or thermo luminescent dosimeter
before our reactor trainees have and
you've worked on nuclear stuff too right
you've got one in the vault wait Kristin
what about you since you've worked
that's exactly what this is yeah and you
can shake it at rattles right yep
exactly so that's this is how these work
that stands for a thermo luminescent
dosimeter and converting from Latin to
English that means if you heat it it
produces light proportional to the dose
that it gets so these little crystals
aluminum oxide or some sort of a salt or
whatever have you something that creates
permanent ionized defects will relax
when you heat them giving off light and
then you use a light counter to tell how
much dose this crystal has received and
by putting different filters in the way
for different pieces and looking at the
light coming from different parts you
can tell different types of dose so one
works for beta's because betas can get
through the little hole in the detector
whereas this may help you figure out
gammas or neutrons of different energies
and who here seeing one of these ring
badges yeah so again the reactor
trainees great if you shake them you
hear a little rattling try it next time
they're usually pretty loose it's a
cheap plastic crappy casting with a
thermal luminescent crystal in the
inside so again shake it it should
rattle if it doesn't the crystal might
be missing and you should probably get a
new one so when you read a TLD it's they
use this fancy machine all it does is
heat it very carefully and allow the
electrons that are trapped at a higher
energy to jump back down emitting
visible light that's it we've seen this
process before what happens after the
photoelectric effect electrons fall down
an energy and release light in the form
of x-rays or visible light same thing
and then let's talk about how can you
use dosimeter x' for dosimetry in
medical applications and let's take the
example of proton beam therapy the new
and more upcoming replacement to x-ray
therapy it relies on the fact that the
stopping power of protons is extremely
low until they reach the end of their
range like we talked about here so again
we use protons as armor
piercing bullets to get through the
person drilling a little hole in the
process and exploding once they reach
the tumor it's a nice quirk of physics
it's really an elegant use of the stuff
in 2201 to do damage where you want it
to there's all sorts of other methods of
cancer treatment let's say you simple
and you can just go with exigent which
means cutting it out chemotherapy which
is a pretty nasty process and it's
usually used as a backup for radiation
therapy to catch whatever else might be
floating x-ray therapy which is still
used a lot but hopefully we'll get
phased out a bit
brachytherapy where you implant a little
seed of a beta emitter into the an area
near where the tumor is let's say you
have an easy route of entry like that
way then you can implant one of these
seeds right where the tumor is but if
you can't have an easy route of entry
that's where proton therapy comes in and
as we talked about x-ray therapy if you
want to damage the tumor more than the
rest of the brain or the rest of the
person you have to come in from
different angles so that the sum of all
the dose to this target is less than
anywhere else and x-ray therapy tends to
do a lot of damage well you hear of
x-ray therapy causing hair loss and
people well yeah you're going through
the head it's not good for your hair
follicles either
and then there's proton therapy we've
talked about it before but not in the
strict medical sense and actually going
to reveal to you guys a invention that
we've got out of our department that
might help this go a little better the
way it works is you start with a
cyclotron which I've already explained
something that accelerates charged
particles to about 250 MeV and we have
one of these across the river at Mass
General Hospital send them through
bending magnets and bend them up so that
they hit the patient then you move the
patient on this gurney or table so then
the gantry can rotate anywhere to come
in from any entry point minimize the
dose to the rest of the patient while
frying the tumor
yep quite big yeah it's pretty to scale
yeah so time on this instrument runs in
the thousands per hour if you go through
the back door and know the folks that
run the thing and know when it's not
being used for cancer treatments proton
therapy can run in the hundreds of
thousands of dollars this is one of the
millions of reasons we have medical
insurance because when you need it you
want it and these cyclotrons aren't
cheap
the way they work is pretty simple you
inject ionized particles through these D
magnets and they go faster and faster
and faster every time they cross this
electric field they Bend at larger and
larger tracks through these magnets as
their energy increases then they exit
out the other side getting delivered to
the patient and why protons versus x-ray
this well I made a quick desmos graph to
say let's say you started off with
equivalent dose of protons and x-rays
and you're trying to get to a forty
millimeter deep tumor this is why this
is the amount of dose that the x-rays
would give compared to the protons in
this highlighted tumor region then you
look at the dose where x-rays and
protons give to the rest of the person
it should be graphically obvious and you
can do some tricks with proton therapy
if you have a long tumor you can vary
the energy and time at each point such
that you give a uniform dose to the
tumor so you can move that Bragg peak by
degrading the proton energy by putting
filters in line with the beam you don't
tend to like to change the energy of the
beam so you can put things in the way of
the protons to slow them down and
because when the stopping power is very
low the protons speed is very high and
forward scattering is preferable putting
things in the way of the beam pretty
much just slows them down but doesn't
change their direction that breaks that
assumption breaks down when the energy
gets low but when the energy gets low
you better be in the tumor anyway and
you want them to change direction and
explode out and blast everything in
sight the problem with proton therapy is
that humans are not biological organisms
that static equilibrium in other words
they're alive
they tend to move breathing is something
I like to do every few seconds
swallowing maybe once every couple
minutes and most of your organs move
around and dance without your
controlling them that's really hard if
you're trying to hit a tumor on a moving
target that is the main problem with
proton therapy the the solution right
now I like to call it spray-and-pray
you fire into the person hope that
things don't move we know that they do
though those proton beams are very
narrow and let's say for abdominal
patients let's say you happen to be
digesting something your intestines will
just go crush lock like that and get
lunch where it's going this is one of
those reasons that they say don't eat
anything before these procedures if
you're not actively digesting things
then your abdomen won't be moving as
much thorax six patients better known as
the lungs or your thorax if you're from
France my wife likes to make I like to
make fun of my wife that's right she
still refers to this region as the
thorax and I was like I am NOT a giant
beetle but it is the it is the medical
term for this you tend to breathe and if
you actually measure how much you move
when you breathe in and out let's say
you're trying to fry a lung tumor that's
a tricky proposition so how do you keep
the protons on track ideally some
dosimeter would be able to determine
absolute dose and it would be able to
where on this list of things is oh
there's even more things I'd want here
so ideally if you'd want a proton dose
immuno you want to be able to measure
things provide some data not be
orientation dependent and things like
not be toxic be cheap to build but also
be able to turn on and off if the tumor
moves out of range and this problem
hasn't been solved yet existing
dosimetry methods include making
calculations and hoping which is what we
do now we do complex Monte Carlos
calculations based on scans of the
patient try and map out how much energy
is going to be lost and where to go in
there's conventional port films which
means you put a film on the entry of the
patient which gives you an idea of where
the beam is but not necessarily where
the organ is let me get into some
pictures of these things so you know
what they look like anyone ever put one
of these in your mouth
the sort of electronic dosimeter their
x-ray images that you get at the dentist
you bite down on one of these and you
get x-rays of your teeth that's great if
you have a place to put them
but doesn't quite work for proton
therapy there are tissue equivalent gels
where you can cast a person in gel fire
in the proton beam and see how deep it
goes and then hope that your tissue
equivalent gel is equivalent to the
tissue usually is pretty good there's
silicon diodes you can implant a tiny
little diode or other semiconductor
device near or in the patient and
measure the change in bandgap or the
voltage required to turn on conduction
in the semiconductor the problem is you
can only use them once once you array D
8 AP s-- of silicon its irradiated and
then you would have to take it out and
stick another one in with a big needle
to keep going
there's optically stimulated
luminescence which means protons hit
stuff stuff creates light light can be
measured in real time so you could
implant a little crystal like this TLD
or thermo luminescence emitter attached
to a fiber-optic cable and in that way
you can measure the amount of light and
pre amplify it PM means what is it
photomultiplier tube and use electronics
and software to calculate that light and
turn it into dose problem is this
scintillation it's not very strong
there's a lot that can go wrong between
where the radiation is done and where it
can be collected also implanted MOSFETs
are these metal-oxide-semiconductor
field-effect transistors same problem
you can look at the change in difference
let's say I'm sorry the change in
bandgap as you--as radiates these things
or in the mosfet voltage but again you
can only use them once it's not like you
can reset them so the problems with all
of these is we don't know what dose the
tumor gets if we know how much we need
to fry it but we don't know if we fried
it the cancer could recur or it may not
respond to the radiation these are
liability terms to say it didn't work
but you can't sue us because we don't
know why and you don't know why or you
may apply too much dose to the
surrounding tissue and induce
secondary tumors this is one of those
things that's not talked about very much
except in medical circles and my entire
family happens to be in medical circles
so they confirm yeah this is true
we don't know how many times if you
treat a tumor do you induce another one
that will pop up five years later in the
same site all you may think is okay it
recurred
despite being dead for five years it
might not have recurred it might have
made a new one you don't know the dose
rate versus time the existing in
situates haven't worked very well so we
had another idea that I'll go in the
last negative one minutes what we call
the integrating F Center feedback
dosimeter we just got the patent filed
on this not accepted but filed with the
US Patent Office it's pretty simple you
send in calibrated light into a little
crystal of something that creates these
color centers or F centers when it's
irradiated look at the light coming out
see what's absorbed you know how much
dose you've received and so the look at
these three these parts a is just an
alkali halide salt better known as table
salt sodium chloride B is some
biocompatible casing so your body
doesn't reject it calibrated white light
source fiber-optic connection cables and
a spectrometer to read the absorption
these can be little compact USB
spectrometers and it relies on what's
called F centers when you were radiate
ionic materials they change color these
defects produced by let's say blasting
out a chlorine ion or a sodium or
potassium ion are optically active
because you get differing regions of
electron density and you absorb certain
wavelengths of light changing their
color if you then send calibrated light
through it you can tell what happened
how much dose there was an F Center
creation versus radiation is extremely
well known we've actually done some
preliminary tests on the Dante
accelerator here to show that the amount
of dose that you give in a fractional
cancer treatment on the order of a
kilogram so does cause these salts to
respond very strongly and produce a
color and the best part is they relax on
their own after anywhere from five
seconds to a few hours the color just
disappears because the atomic defects
relaxed so you don't have to employ
remove re-implant remove and you can
able dose rate information by putting
multiple salts in a row that have
different response levels to this these
protons so by looking at the amount of
absorption in each wavelength you can
tell not just the dose but the dose rate
calibrate your beam current and I want
to skip all the way to the end to say
how this would work so let's say you had
one of these I F 2d dosimeter z'
implanted in your tumor and your heart
was beating or your lungs were breathing
or you were digesting something you
could then feedback this information to
the proton accelerator to shut the beam
off when the tumor moves out of range
and send in tiny little pulses to say
hey are you there little micro second
pulses to say like microsecond of - of
protons isn't going to do much but if it
senses the aia i f2 was at i f.2d back
and range it then blasts continuously
and as soon as the I F 2d says no more
dose it starts just putting those wakeup
pulses back on so this would be a the
first feedback way to apply proton
therapy without screwing it up you can
also install if2 D dosimeter z' near the
tumor outside the tumor and play the
work for a world's first game of
radioactive proton operation
don't hit the sides if you wonder if
your beams on target you then steer it
until it doesn't hit any of the I f2 DS
and you know you're right through the
gates on the tumor very important for
certain sensitive tumors like chordomas
spinal cord tumors which tend to happen
in infants and young children yeah you
know the work there's various ways of
treating those other than removal of the
neck what you don't want to do
they're extremely difficult to operate
on you don't want to give radiation
therapy so highly targeted proton
therapy like this making sure that you
fry the tumor without the surrounding
spinal cord and medulla would be
probably the way to go for this so I'm
gonna stop there because it's exactly
10:00 it's also the perfect stopping
point and we'll pick up with background
radiation tomorrow I also want to let
you guys know that we'll be doing our
nuclear activation analysis a radiations
Friday at the beginning of recitation
and we'll finish off recitation by
doing the museum review
you